have um a chapter that's the first
chapter is black rednecks and white
liberals the second chapter is are Jews
generic MH why the jump well this book
is RAR about ethnic and cultural issues
in general so there's a chapter on the
Jews there a chapter on the Germans and
then there's a chapter on history in
general so that the question is why this
particular kind of people are the
targets of so much us venomous hatred
and I think the answer is that um they
not they not only succeed they succeed
in a way which is the threat to the egos
of other people years ago one uh
official of one of the Jewish
organizations in New York asked me what
what can Jews themselves do uh in order
to minimize the hostility they face I
gave him a one- word answer
fail because as long as you succeed
you're going to be hated that is why
they particularly hate Israel because
it's a place where not only Jews are
succeeding uh but then Jews refuse to
fail and they've got weapons to make
sure that that doesn't happen